on this Tuesday night the federal budget
and what it means for you the promise to
Target inflation relief these are
significant and necessary Investments
and the Billion Dollar Bet on Canada's
green economy having government support
is really critical what that means for
this country's energy sector you give us
a problem we will find the solution
community in mourning the calls for more
resources after another Canadian police
officer is killed on the job plus the
onazcom in Israel we're in a ceasefire
rather than an internal domestic peace a
fire defense minister refuses to step
down how politics in Israel is in
disarray
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
federal government has released its 2023
budget and dental care inflation relief
and incentives for investors in the
green economy are top priorities so is
reining in some of the costs of running
the government the budget projects
spending will reach nearly 491 billion
dollars in the coming fiscal year with
the deficit on track to hit 40 billion
dollars our chief political
correspondent David Aiken spent the day
digesting all the budget documents David
take us through the biggest points sure
well I think this is the seventh liberal
budget since the Trudeau government took
over it's probably the most modest and I
think what the Finance Minister
Christopher Freeland is trying to do
here is really balance three objectives
first of all she wants to shore up the
country's fiscal foundation in
anticipation there may be slower
economic growth ahead two she wants to
set the economy on a new green path to
the Future and then third and perhaps
most importantly I think she wants to
help out the millions of Canadians who
right now are having a hard time dealing
with the rapidly rising cost of living
notice what this budget invests in
possibility for every single Canadian to
share in the remarkable opportunities
that Canada provides and in the new era
of prosperity that we will build
together the budget centerpiece is a
one-time cost of living rebate worth 467
dollars for couples with children
234 dollars for single Canadians and an
extra 225 dollars for seniors the
government is calling it a grocery
rebate but you can spend it on anything
you want it will be paid out to 11
million Canadians when that's TBD given
the pressures that household budgets are
under I can imagine any amount is going
to be helpful the government also
promises to lower credit card
transaction fees for businesses and
prohibit what it calls hidden junk fees
that consumers pay things like roaming
charges or surcharges for concert
tickets even excess baggage fees
Freeland also to announce an expansion
of what is now called the Canadian
dental care plan that's a plan that had
covered dental bills for children in
lower income households now by the end
of 2023 any uninsured person in a
household earning less than ninety
thousand dollars can get Federal dental
coverage the government is also scaling
back a planned tax hike on beer Wine and
Spirits the alcohol excise tax will now
jump two percent on April the first
rather than six and a half percent
overall new spending commitments total
43 billion dollars over the next five
years and most of that is a result of
increased Health transfers to the
provinces this is I think a bit of a
pivot for for this liberal government
it's a relatively small budget the
government says its budget plan is
sustainable
our country has a proud tradition of
fiscal responsibility
that is the tradition we are determined
to uphold
now as for political reaction the
conservatives say too much spending
they're not going to vote for it the
block quebecois says not enough spending
they're not going to vote for it but of
course Justin Trudeau and jugmead Sig
did a deal in 2022 they made in some
arrangements and there's a lot in this
budget the NDP will vote for so I don't
think there'll be much drama Donna this
budget is going to pass the house of
comets okay David Aiken thank you a
major focus of the budget is the
so-called green economy to build the
clean technology sector in Canada and
create jobs the investment in green
energy is also meant to respond to U.S
policies that are heavily subsidizing
that sector Toria Israel is looking at
what was in the budget to address that
turia
Donna the second biggest item in the
budget after health is boosting clean
energy the government is spending almost
20 billion dollars over the next few
years on green jobs and Technology the
Liberals are trying to sell it as the
most significant transformation since
the Industrial Revolution
[Applause]
are for everyone everywhere from our
biggest cities to our smallest towns
the government is spending 18 and a half
billion dollars over the next five years
on things like clean tech manufacturing
clean hydrogen and carbon capture and
storage much of the money will come in
the form of tax credits which could be a
boost to companies like this Edmonton
startup it is really challenging so
having government support uh is is
really critical that support is meant to
keep Canada competitive the U.S is
spending massively on green jobs as part
of the inflation reduction act we would
have liked to see more more talk about
fossil fuels we know that the climate
crisis is fundamentally an issue of
fossil fuel production fossil fuel
consumption we know that fossil fuels
are also a really important part of the
Canadian economy and we need to have a
mature conversation about that the
Federal government is also trying to
polyev proof the carbon tax by signing
business contracts to make sure the
program lasts other green measures are
aimed right at the pocketbook
Ottawa wants a universal charger to work
on all devices Apple or Android to cut
down on waste and costs the Liberals are
also bringing in a right to repair to
make it cheaper and easier to fix home
appliances electronics and farming
equipment the Liberals are also pledging
two billion dollars over the next five
years to improve service at Canada's
struggling airports but
pay slightly more for airline tickets
security charges are going up between
five and ten dollars next year Donna
rituria isri thank you and With Me Now
from Ottawa is the Finance Minister and
the Deputy Prime Minister Christian
Freeland Miss Freeland thanks so much
for taking time with us can we start
with the big picture A number of
analysts and groups such as the
conference Board of Canada anticipate
Canada will slip into a recession in the
next 12 months what's your view on that
is it inevitable well no one gave me a
crystal ball when I became Finance
Minister but what I can tell you is what
the average of the predictions of
private sector economists who we
surveyed and whose forecasts we use as
the base case for the budget was and
what they're forecasting is a Slowdown
of the Canadian economy what they would
call a technical a mild recession this
year with
0.3 percent decline in the first quarter
0.8 decline in the second quarter 0.3 in
the third quarter and the good news a
comeback of 1.1 percent in the fourth
quarter of this year it's so far what we
have seen is employment is remaining
really really strong there are still
job vacancies being advertised out there
and so even as the economy is slowing
down we're not seeing yet that kind of
personal pain which I think people
associate with an economy that's slower
you're projecting a deficit about 10
billion dollars higher than initially
forecasts the official opposition says
there's far too much spending in this
budget that they call it an attack on
hard-working people in this country
what's your rebuttal to that you know I
have two rebuttals Donna the first thing
I would say is so what would you cut
would you cut the grocery rebate checks
to the most vulnerable Canadians I sure
wouldn't because I think those 11
million Canadian households really need
a little extra support would you cut the
investment that we announced in February
in Canada's Health Care system or the
expansion of the dental care system I
sure wouldn't do that I think Canadians
rightly rely on our Universal Public
Health Care system and Canadians know we
needed some more money to make it work
and then the final thing I'd ask is
would you cut our investments in the
clean economy this is a fiscally
responsible budget yes we have made the
necessary essential Investments we need
to make in Canadians but we have done
that within a fiscally responsible
framework the GST rebate or the grocery
rebate as you're calling it when are
Canadians going to get it
okay I cannot say precisely because
delivering this stuff takes time
um but you know within the next
within the next couple of months how's
that all right Finance Minister and
Deputy Prime Minister Chris here
Freeland thanks
the opposition leader Pierre pauliev
said he doesn't support the spending in
this budget he says conservatives will
be voting against the plan to add what
he calls billions of new inflationary
debt and tax hikes on things like heat
gas and groceries
today's
budget by the costly Coalition of the
NDP and liberals is at a full frontal
attack on the paychecks of hard-working
Canadians it equals forty two hundred
dollars per family in new government
spending that's more inflation more
taxes and more costs for everyday people
there's no common sense
reaching ottawa's net zero emissions
Target is a focus of the budget there
are billions in tax credits available to
companies that are in the clean
technology sector Canada is competing
with the U.S which has unveiled a 370
billion dollar program of tax credits
and subsidies for electric vehicles
batteries and renewable energy projects
if they are American-made the government
doesn't want Canadians to be left behind
Heather urich's West reports
in Red Deer Alberta on a street called
Energy way you won't find any
multinational oil Giants raking in
records setting cash I've been involved
in the oil and gas industry in
construction for 23 years now
instead you'll find plenty of energy
industry entrepreneurs small business
owners like James Pierce who are used to
booms busts and an ever-present need to
change that's going on a rig his
two-year-old company sells hydrogen
on-demand units for drilling rakes and
heavy trucks we inject hydrogen in
through your turbo and it mixes and
blends with your Diesel and gives you
fuel savings right after that and also
reduces your emissions the small
business is Pierce's own idea of a just
transition finding a way to work within
the energy sector to forge a cleaner
path if you look at the Energy Services
sector we always say we're the
innovators and solution finders so you
give us a problem we will find the
solution though this industry Advocate
says the sector could use some help
along the way pointing to the clean
energy incentives in the U.S inflation
reduction act what they have done is
provided a roadmap and Canada just needs
to follow
suit and and provide the same
opportunities to our members here the
words just transition or sustainable
jobs plan are politically divisive in
this province the current Premier is
definitely not a fan but what about
Alberta's workers themselves we ran a
poll in 2021 and what we saw is the
overwhelming majority of workers that
are currently working in the oil and gas
and coal sector are very interested in a
career in the net zero Industries iron
and Earth a group of former oil sands
workers turned advocates for the energy
transition say what workers need is more
support
whether it's from Ottawa or whoever
forms Alberta's next government in a few
weeks time Heather urich's West Global
News Red Deer Alberta
coming up a Quebec police officer killed
on the Drone
a Quebec Provincial Police Officer and a
suspect died last night after an
attempted arrest it happened in the town
of Louisville it's about an hour east of
Montreal police say they were responding
to a dispute about a man uttering
threats at an apartment complex Sergeant
Maureen bro was stabbed to death she is
the eighth police officer to die on the
job in this country in the past six
months Phil Carpenter reports
an electronic sign just outside
Louisville City Hall Bears the Grim news
of a community in mourning Sergeant
Maureen bro a 20 plus year veteran of
the Quebec Provincial Police lost her
life following an incident Monday night
at an apartment on Saint Laurent Avenue
in Louisville
law enforcement Representatives say it's
a tragedy for the entire police
Community authorities say around 8 30
Monday night bro and another officer
responded to a call about a disturbance
at a private home according to the Bei
the provincial body responsible for
investigating police intervention that
result in the fatality when the peer-off
officers tried to arrest a 35 year old
male suspect Sergeant bro was stabbed
she fell from a balcony and was later
declared dead in hospital the Bei says
the suspect was fatally shot by another
police officer who was called as backup
the other officer who was with bro was
also injured the town's mayor says the
incident is a tragedy and believes the
suspect could have had a mental health
crisis
foreign he says we're asking police
officers to be social workers and
psychologists and that's not their job
and said there should be more
psychosocial support to avoid incidents
like this the head of the Union
representing the Provincial Police
agrees that policing has become more
complex especially in interventions
involving people in mental distress
strategic he says these days officers
have to face a wide range of risks and
they must be careful P2 is asking for
more resources the investigation is
ongoing Phil Carpenter Global News
Louisville
police in Nashville Tennessee have
released body camera footage from two
officers who police say fatally shot the
suspect who killed six people at a
private Christian Elementary School they
also say the attack was pre-planned the
body cam footage is dramatic we're not
showing all of it but it could be
disturbing to some
door door
with me with me four minutes after they
arrived at the school police say they
located and shot the 28 year old suspect
Audrey Elizabeth Hale they say is a
former student who was under doctors
care for what police call an emotional
disorder the city's police chief says
the suspect bought at least seven
firearms legally from five different
stores across Nashville including two
assault rifles and a pistol used to
carry out the mass shooting police are
working on a motive they found a
detailed map of the school showing entry
points and a Manifesto that indicates
the killer may have been planning to
attack other locations
in Mexico at least 39 people are dead
and an immigration Detention Center just
south of El Paso Texas the Mexican
president says people held at the center
fearing deportation set mattresses on
fire it's believed 68 men were inside
when the blaze broke out Crews rushed to
the scene to try to help the victims
reported to be from Central and South
America it is one of Mexico's deadliest
Fires at an immigration lockup
political uncertainty ahead will a delay
on controversial legal reforms calm
unrest in Israel
[Music]
Israel's political future hangs in the
balance now that the Prime Minister has
agreed to delay his judicial reforms
they are deeply unpopular even with
senior people in Benjamin netanyahu's
own government he fired the defense
minister but that minister is refusing
to leave Crystal gemancing Reports from
Tel Aviv on the political disarray in
Israel
a wave of democracy chants drumming and
blaring horns
this anti-reform demonstrator says the
Prime Minister pausing his judicial
reforms is an act of manipulation
something to buy him time in hopes that
the people will settle down experts say
what's unfolding in Israel as a result
of Benjamin Netanyahu looking to give
the government more control over the
courts is remarkable prime minister
Netanyahu never dealt with such a
pushback from Israeli public Israeli
Civil Society we're in a ceasefire
rather than an internal domestic peace
between the different parts of Israeli
Society
Monday saw some of the biggest
demonstrations protesters and police
fighting in the streets it followed
Netanyahu firing his defense minister
after he criticized the reforms saying
they risked National Security turns out
that minister is still at work having
not been directly notified about his
termination I think the whole country
can take a deep breath after three
months of being at the edge of the cliff
I think Bibi made the right move
stopping the progress of the reforms and
listening to the voice of the protesters
while negotiations on creating more
palatable reforms are underway the
far-right religious party of itamar
bengavir has stated publicly the reforms
will pass it's his party that keeps
Netanyahu in office with a coalition
government the courts may need more
checks and balances but what's been
proposed is not acceptable to many and
those Israelis plan to make sure the
government doesn't forget it
Donna all right crystal gemancing in Tel
Aviv thanks
budget breakdown next the biggest
takeaways from the federal government's
spending plan
[Music]
let's go back to Ottawa and talk about
the federal budget Mercedes Stevenson
our Ottawa bureau chief is with me
Mercedes economists analysts anticipate
Canada will head into recession in the
next 12 months will that be the test of
this budget whether the government can
keep the country on an even keel
well Donna it's the challenge
politically because of course the
government is held accountable for how
they fare in any coming difficult
economic Waters and there's
realistically only so much that the
federal government can control for when
you look at what's happening with U.S
banks or concerns about the global
economy and inflation those are things
that Christian Freeland can't stop but
if things go south you know that she
will be blamed for it so what you see in
this document and we held it up in our
federal budget special but I'll hold it
up for our viewers again it is really
thin for a liberal government budget in
fact it's then for a Harper government
budget so this is not the typical big
spending and that's a recognition that
they are concerned about the effect that
kind of spending could have on inflation
and possible currency devaluation as
well but at the same time they're trying
to put some of these big programs in the
window that they've promised and of
course you see a lot of retail politics
in this budget things that they hope
will attract people's attention whether
it's the baggage fees or the universal
charger for your phone and those are
things that they are hoping will
resonate their vote vulnerability on it
Remains the tax issue that's something
that Pierre pauliev was attacking today
and it's something that people get more
riled about as they feel that squeeze
coming in so how this all fares to some
degree will be at the government's feet
but regardless of what these sort of
economic Trade Winds do they will be the
ones who are left holding the bag and
quickly Mercedes one place where the
government was vulnerable was on their
Reliance heavy Reliance on private
Consultants how are they changing that
well they've recognized that that was a
political liability for them
particularly when they weren't looking
to cut programs and this is a government
that has significantly significantly
grown the bureaucracy so they are vowing
to spend less on those Consultants they
are trying to send the signal that they
are looking for places where they can
cut without actually digging into
Federal programs it's something they
were politically concerned about and we
see that reflected here okay Mercedes
Stevenson and the foyer of the House of
Commons thanks
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the devil's oven ice caves in
Minto New Brunswick we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you